the Joe Rogan experience yeah I went
through that I had two nightclubs at one
time but I never bothered with the money
part at all I just just worried about
the stage and the mic was working and
there was a suite in Vancouver when how
long it was us
this was sixties in this yeah you have
night clubs like comedy clubs or like
well one one was an after-hours sort of
like a jazz dance bottle club and it was
given to me see there again you know hey
hey tell me you went a club and I said
sure the guy buddy give you a club yeah
well he bought a building mm-hmm and
back and then back in the day you know
there was a steak house in the basement
he says fare the cheers pay rent when
when you can what
so I went in what was this guy's deal he
owned buildings most people that own
buildings don't be giving them away oh
yeah what they do
rent free rent yes all the time you can
get a year's free rent
just cuz they want to get someone in the
belly but that you get it you get it
going see soon as we started being
successful we were paying I said $500 a
month rent so he got you going so we we
made a ton of money in there and that's
where I got the bands you know that's
where I honed my skills as a musician
and a singer and and all that and then I
got offered another club because it was
going under and it was a dine and dance
club in Chinatown and I thought yeah I
make a great strip club and so so we
took it over the Shanghai junk turned it
into a strip club
Vancouver's first strip club and then
you were the proprietor of Vancouver's
first ever source of strip club last one
and in fact we did a in fact we did a a
midnight mass at a church I think we had
this stripper dancing at the church but
not stripping she kept my clothes I know
what she danced oh that's appropriate
yeah yeah you gotta get you it there's a
legend when did you start getting in the
live shows well
when I got fired from Motown because I
had to get a green card and not nobody
at Motown knew what a green card was and
so I had to miss a gig to get my green
card I got the green card and I came
back and I got fired
and so then Berry Gordy found out about
it he saw you're not fired I said that I
think I'll stay fired I'm gonna be a
Berry Gordy I don't work for one and so
then I came out to LA and tried to live
on the beach and be a songwriter but
then my clubs were calling me because
they needed help so I went back and I
turned the strip club into an
improvisational Club so we're doing
naked improv it was great
all the girls there were actor they're
strippers and that once I turned him
into actresses they were a lot cheaper
and they're a lot more beautiful later
talk they did skits and then they would
take off their clothes when they had to
but within within you know the script
and that's where I met Cheech because we
had a straight guy and a straight guy's
wife found out what he was doing and
hauled him away and then she came on
board as a straight guy and then when
Vancouver yeah and Vancouver yeah but
teaches in LA guy right yeah he was up
there in case the Vietcong attacked from
Alaska so he was hiding from the draft
well not really he well not really he
was trying to stay out of the way let's
put it down to move and then then he had
a sneak back in Dowling yeah but it was
easy coming in into LA from Canada he
just showed someone else's ID and they
said back in the day yeah who world was
slot slipper here yeah and that's so
that's why I'm saying I I'm so blessed
you know because everything the universe
and it was from the each change started
one of the guitar players turned me on
to the II Ching back then and and my
reading was perfection you're going to
be everything is perfect you're gonna
really do well
and then Cheech and Chong and all that
stuff happened here we are and you guys
are touring again
yeah all right how long you been torn
again once you guys get back together
Oh 808 yeah 11 years how crazy is that
that that's 11 years ago that doesn't
seem like 11 years ago we say oh wait
it's like it just happened and you're
like oh no it's 2019 so almost 2020 no
no that that train keeps the ruling
never stops
what is this Jamie this is Bobby Taylor
in the Vancouver's whoa that's me that's
you yeah how old were you there 20 Bobby
Taylor in the Vancouver's twice I kind
of sunglasses off yeah they did it even
back then Wow Bobby Taylor in the
Vancouver that's the motel on Sunset
Strip is that you with the yellow jacket
which ones yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
you yeah Wow that's crazy
and then we oh we went over to England
met Jimi Hendrix whoa and changed our
lives
this is way we looked when we went over
there and we came back long hair
everybody wore different clothes Wow now
when you went from this to comedy yeah
like how did you make that leap well
nobody really knew that I could talk you
know I was in a black band so everybody
else you know I was a guitar player so
you know I had nothing to say other than
I owned the club and no one knew that no
him and I was always a backup guitar
player when I got into comedy Wallace
was doing what happened I had hired when
I turned the strip club into an improv
of improvisation Club I hired the act we
already had which was a black tap dancer
named taps Harris and Jeannie a black
singer and they had a band and so I the
first get I had tap the first get was
about a
a party that all the strippers were
having at their house after and that's
so they always change into their pajamas
and in their little nighties and that
was very sexy and then tap schemes comes
by after the show you know so-called and
and they say a taps do that number that
you did on the show and so taps first
time he ever tap danced you know in
front of a live audience because usually
it was just an MC so he did his tap
dance and then and it was so good that
everybody wanted to hang car that's so
they made him do an encore
he quit that night it really it's too
hard work he was hired to just Danny and
here goes low low and so at the dorm an
English guy named Dave and so I said
Dave I need an emcee you know he says
well I'll do it if you do it and so I
okay and so we became Dave was my first
partner and so we started we had long
hair we're like hippies and so we we did
a lot of hippies and T&A jokes you know
tits and ass domes and and then then and
we had a guitar player named gate alarm
he brought the big hit you know that
during my I he wrote the music and so
gay was this incredible guitarist and he
could do all sort of but he was like
very funny funny funny guy and so we
wrote a skit you know where we did would
torture the audience they're all biker
mostly bikers didn't come to a strip bar
you know you didn't bikers do that and
so the first act we had it mom because
when we turned it into a theater company
but we attracted all the theater people
all the performers you know there was a
stage or boy who go work there and so we
had a mime artist and so we opened the
show with a mime artist and gay playing
classical guitar he's playing this class
of guitar now this is a strip joint and
all the hardened bikers are sitting
around waiting for naked girls to come
home and here comes a here comes a mime
artist you know so Brittany's he's
picking flowers and smelling them and
throwing them
pants and around the stage and and so
the biker sat through that you know they
were yelling things like hey Elvis their
remarks weren't that funny and then and
then Dave would come out and Dave's a
very funny looking guy it looks like
looks like an improv actor and he come
out and he and he sings this horrible
song I Dream of Jeannie with the light
brown hair Jeannie is my favorite wired
hair Terrier and then just when the
bikers are getting ready to revolt I
opened I kicked the door open we had
doors on the back you know and I kicked
the door open and my shirtless my hair
is messed up and I got a rolled-up
newspaper and I walked over to Dave I go
what kind of [ __ ] song is that I beat
him to death with this newspaper and the
bikers just they explode the whole joint
just exploded you know laughter because
we had we've created that tension hmm
that long and then relieved the release
was like it's a roar and then the word
went out boom in that place was packed
almost every night wow what a weird
world that must have been back then look
at this the city works yeah there we are
there's days that Terkel sexy at the
Shanghai which others teach in the
superb right
wow that's Cheech that's crazy that's
cheap that's Dave and that's me Wow
without uh without a goatee and that's
my Martha says Ian the my name artist
and it's windy Maureen and Shirley Wow
what a weird world is it crazy looking
at that oh yeah memories huh starting
Tuesday yeah
[Applause]